there we go
okay good evening good evening everybody
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is cancer
peter richards i will be chairing the
meeting this evening uh if i may as a
few housekeeping things to start with
first of all mobile phones if you could
please make sure they are at the very
least on silent ideally off but i
understand some people need to use them
so if they can be on silent that's fine
just as long as they don't disturb the
flow of the meeting we aren't expecting
a fire alarm um if one does go off don't
panic follow us meet us at the car park
next to the windmill and we will check
that everyone is out safely and sound
um this tonight's meeting is a meeting
in public it is not a public meeting so
only those people that are registered to
speak will be uh will be able to do so
uh i will call you forward at the
appropriate time you can choose from any
one of the three desks in front of us we
have put out some hand sanitizer um and
also some sanitizing surface wipes if
you want to use them on the desks and or
on the microphones please feel free to
do so if you're not worried that's
absolutely fine as well
um
okay i think that's all we need to worry
about we are being recorded in live
streams just bear that in mind when you
are sat and speaking
let's get into the agenda proper um
could i please have polish for absence
so i haven't done my introductions i am
so sorry i should have done that let me
introduce everyone to you first so on my
far right we have sophie jarrett who is
our committee services to my immediate
right we have mason nash who is our
solicitor and our planners in no
particular order are lancia agnew louise
casey and alice kozner alice is our
planning manager alice i believe you've
got a statement to make
thank you chairman my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thanks thank
you very much now let's get into the
meeting proper apologies for absence
please
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors adam and dixon tonight
thank you very much members do we have
any disclosures of interest please
counselor mills first thanks mr chairman
uh on item four on the planning
application when we will farm red horse
fail i do i have bought some uh
materials from there and we do have our
central heating oil and i bought fences
so
but it won't declare my judgment
hopefully i'm still going to stay on we
will allow it thank you very much
chancellor fleming
yeah
that's just reminding me i've got two
things to declare then uh i'm a customer
at red horse
we've got five horses so you can imagine
we're spending quite a bit of money in
their place
so that's that's one thing and the other
one is the application for white gay was
at bidford it was in barton um
that's been through bidford parish
council which i'm sure but i excused
myself from the meeting so i took no
part so i'm not predetermined on this
meeting tonight marvis thank you very
much just taking that first item so
windmill farm i think it's fair to say
that we all know uh one of the speakers
on that item um i'm certainly here with
a night in mind i'm going to assume that
everyone else is
i'm seeing lots of nodding so well
that's a cover all for that item uh did
i see any other disclosures that any
other hands go up
no okay marvelous everyone happy with
the minutes from our last meeting
just lots of nodding and
yeah all good i will sign those after
tonight's meeting now we are having a
slight rejig in terms of the running
order of um the applications um we are
bringing forward the the final item
which is uh 11 to 13 white gates well
for road button to be heard first um so
we will take that one now our
presentation officer is louise casey
louise over to you
thank you chairman let me just share my
screen
so this application is for single-story
extensions to the front and rear of an
existing dwelling the application site
is situated within the village of barton
and is shown here by the black dot
the application site is outlined red in
red here it sits within the barton
conservation area and is identified as
being of individual local interest and
local group value within the barton
conservation air report
the site also lies in close proximity to
a number of listed buildings number nine
wealth of road and the cottage of
content pub being the closest
you can also see here there's a public
footpath which starts here and runs
north
so here's an aerial view of the site
we've got
pub here pub car park
oh [ __ ]
is that better
sorry about that minor technical glitch
do you need me to go back or should i
carry on i think probably people at home
haven't been able to hear you so if you
wouldn't talk again yeah i think
it's working now which is fun
okay
sorry to everyone here has to hear this
all again
the application site the application is
for single-story extensions to the front
and rear of the existing dwelling the
application site is situated within the
village of barton and is shown here by
the black dot
the application site is outlined here in
red it sits within the barton
conservation area and is identified as
being of individual local interest and
local group value within the
conservation air report the site is also
in close proximity to a number of listed
buildings and we've got a public
footpath here which runs north
we've got an aerial view of the site
here the site is once again outlined in
red we've got the pub here pub car park
um
number nine welford road
so we've got existing and proposed site
plans so on the right on the proposed
site plan we can see the extensions
hatched in yellow
and here we've got the existing and
proposed north and south elevations
which are to undergo the extensions the
building was originally two separate
cottages and is now used as a single
dwelling it's a typical example of local
vernacular being simple and
traditionally designed dating from the
late victorian period
and here we've got the existing and
proposed east and west elevations of the
dwelling so this just gives you an idea
of the overall depth of the extensions
proposed in this slide here we've got
some 3d views the proposed extensions so
the extensions will largely obscure the
original elevations of the house you can
also see that the roof of the proposed
extensions extends above the sill level
of the existing first floor window as
you can see here
so this creates inverted dormers which
are neither traditional or
characteristic of the area
so now moving on to some photos of the
site we've got the southern elevation of
the house here which has been taken from
within the application site here's the
northern elevation of the house and this
photo has been taken from the pub car
park looking towards the site
this photo has been taken from the same
position just panic slightly to the left
so you've got the
sorry we've got the bob on the left here
and the application site over here on
the right
uh and then this photo has just been
taken and stood in front of the pub and
you can see the site in the background
here and then one final photo uh this
has been taken from the welford road
we've got number nine welford road in
the foreground here
pub over here and the site is situated
to the rear of number nine
so please see the update sheet for
written updates in relation to this
application by way of a verbal update it
should be noted that there's an error in
the officer report on the bottom of page
38 of the agenda the concluding
paragraph of the residential immunity
section states that the proposal is not
in accordance with policies cs9 and cs20
whereas it should read that it is in
accordance with these policies so that's
in relation to the residential immunity
section
and chairman is therefore recommended
that the application be refused for the
single reason detailed within the report
thank you
louise thank you very much um let's call
and ask first speaker of the evening who
is counselor penny taylor
good evening and welcome
okay let me find out where they are if
you want to grab yourself a seat
it's all right don't you worry about
that
and presumably when we're going through
the photos you'll just give us a nod so
we know when to move them up
okay
okay well when louise has got the map
you obviously know already you've got uh
three minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning four times up but otherwise
whenever you're ready feel free to start
i'm going to restart the time we're
having a nightmare with our technical
stuff
not a problem not a problem
whenever you're ready start again from
the beginning and i've reset the clock
so hope to you thank you
thank you
um white gates has needed drastic action
to make it habitable and return it to
family use after decades of neglect we
believe these plans as a parish council
believe these plans are practical and
imaginative and will create an asset for
the conservation village to replace an
uninhabitable cyborg i saw
the village department strongly supports
the project in the first identical
application for these extensions which
you may remember from december 21
comments and support were sent in that's
half the village
three more letters of support since been
sent in since that one and there's not
been a single objection
according to the case officer this
application satisfies all planning
issues apart from the impact on
conservation area and nearby listed
buildings
well white gates as you can see you've
seen these pictures is in a conservation
area but is not listed two nearby listed
buildings are mentioned in the report as
you can see letterbox cottage is in
stands in front of it between it and the
main road you can just see it at the
corner of letterbox cottage which by the
way is number six not number nine um
as you can see from the photos white
gates is barely visible from the welford
road or from the lane in front of the
cottage of the content pub and those
views will not change
the only viewers from the cottage of
content and partly
particularly from the car park at the
back of the pub where the dominant view
is actually of the caravan park which
you would have seen in that aerial
photograph
the only
as you can see from the next slides if
you just put the next one up
the nearby architecture is mixed
and this cottage will not be out of
place
the parish council agrees that with the
importance of cs8 in preserving heritage
assets and the officer's report judges
the harm to be less than substantial
which then needs to be measured against
public benefits i do disagree with the
officer's remark that the only benefit
would be to provide a private economic
benefit
the public benefits seem clear to us the
cottage will greatly improve that corner
of the village retain many of its
original features both inside and out
and become a habitable building suitable
for 21st century living
to quote paragraph 208 of the nppf this
will in our belief secure the future
conservation of the heritage asset
env8 of the ndp says the public benefits
should include the need for optimum
viable use of the heritage asset and
cs20 of the core strategy encourages
modifications that enable homeowners to
realize the potential of their property
and improve the quality of their lives
adding that the council supports such
aspirations
in summary the applicant is requesting
two small extensions to enable a
reasonable sized kitchen and living area
fit for the 21st century 30 seconds he
is sympathetically repairing restoring
and reusing original materials wherever
possible and making a real improvement
to the corner of the village the cottage
needs to be lived in loved and
maintained for future generations and
that's why the parish council
unanimously supports this planning
application
council thank you very much well within
your time if you can stay seated just
for a second and see if anyone has any
questions for you members do we have any
questions for the pressure council
turns out not thank you very much for
your time
okay we'll call our second speaker of
the evening who is mr paul talent
good evening
in a similar way you all have three
minutes i'll give you a 30-second
warning grab it grab a seat make
yourself comfortable if we've got
pictures they'll be on the screen in a
second is it just that one slide
so you'll give us a nod when you want
them changing
yep perfect in that case three minutes
i'll give you 30 second warning whenever
you're ready it's over to you
and middle button will turn out perfect
okay
good evening
i'm here this evening to put forward my
views as to why planning application
should be approved by the members of
this committee slide one
um these are views of white gates from
the north
uh the pub car park south
um the rear garden east uh front of pub
and the west from the campsite
on removing the vegetation from the
property and surrounding garden white
gates was found to be in a very poor
state of repair
slide two please
ah thank you
um
these views of white gates with the
vegetation removed
uh slide three
okay a victorian oven house has exposed
them as a surprise to everyone
uh the first picture was taken from the
pub car park
uh as you can see well you can't because
it was covered in vegetation
uh the second is during renovation and
the third is the roof and chimney when
repaired this gives a good indication of
whitegate's condition before work
commenced
uh slide four please
okay
this is the existing kitchen
uh needs replacing oh sorry the existing
kitchen needs replacing as it is not fit
for purpose being constructed of four
inch brickwork and only single skin
the roof consists of
asbestos pink slate
the proposed front lobby of the utility
lobby and utility is of similar size to
the existing kitchen the existing
kitchen is seven meters square and the
proposed replacement is nine point seven
two meters an increase of two point
two eight meters
the appearance of white gates
from the approach to the pub would
change very little
see photo two
slide five please
uh the extension to the south elevation
uh would help
stabilize this part of white gates as it
is in an unstable condition and has
structural issues
uh this area would need replacing
regardless
uh to sum up white gates was advertised
for renovation or demolition when i
first viewed it
i chose the renovation route
thank you
perfect time-wise i was just about to
give you a 30-second warning but
obviously i didn't need one uh members
do you have any questions for mr talon
please
no
very quiet tonight in that case mr tan
thank you very much for your time
contribution
okay our last speaker on this item is
councillor pemberton council hampton to
come forward
welcome you know the drill you have five
minutes you can use as much or as little
as that five minutes as you like and i
will give you a 30 second warning before
that time is up otherwise whenever
you're ready it's over to you
thank you members um and thank you for
the opportunity for speaking to you and
for forbearance in moving the agenda
around for me um
members
to all intents and purposes this is
similar to an application
that you heard before christmas
with the removal of a detached garage
and much of the debate amongst members
did not
circle and center upon the impact of the
heritage asset it's centered upon
parking standards and the inability of
the site to meet parking standards
the officer notes that
that
which was quite
some some matter of debate
is an issue that's been overcome by this
new application
um
members the sole roof reason for refusal
um is in respect of the impact on
the
setting of the listed building
members um
it's my contention
that this development
whilst noting that
it does cover part of the original
framework is a sympathetic
simple
and uh
quite ingenious
uh development
um that will bring back into use uh
property that has been derelict for some
years and for the avoidance of dads has
been two cottages converted into one
many many years ago it is not this
applicant that has converted two into
one um
the officer cites um
policy cs8
policy cs8 is in line with the national
planning policy framework and
particularly under paragraph b
in relation to paragraph 202 of the mppf
and the parish council themselves have
referenced
the
the idea of securing optimum viable use
and i would suggest that this
development does indeed secure optimum
viable use
it is agreed by officers that there is a
less than substantial harm in other
words the lowest possible type of harm
that you can you can get in in terms of
uh heritage and impact on heritage
assets our heritage officer our
conservation officer does not appear to
have commented specifically uh that this
is uh uh
an adverse implication
um i would draw members attention in the
nppf to paragraph 197 paragraph 197 says
in determining applications local
planning authorities should take account
of a number of items a b and c and c
is the desirability of new development
making a positive contribution
to local character and distinctiveness
and i would contend that this is a
subjective matter about the quality of
design and the impact on the heritage
asset of the cottage of content and
neighbouring properties and as decision
makers i believe that you are entitled
to reference 197c
and decide that this application does
indeed make a positive contribution and
that also talks to the question of the
the public benefit which the officer
suggests is solely the economic benefit
and i would contend
members that there is a wider impact and
positive benefit to the scene of barton
the setting of the cottage of content
which currently has a poor setting and
members are entitled to say that indeed
this this application is in conformity
with policy cs8
the officer also references policy env8
of the bid for the naval neighborhood
development plan
earlier today i spent some considerable
time
discussing neighbourhood development
plans and their importance in decision
making at the overview and scrutiny
committee meeting
you have a parish council that has a
neighborhood development plan and its
neighborhood development plans are about
what they
will allow as much as what they will not
allow
and it is the clear contention of the
parish council that this application is
in conformity with policy env8 and
policy env8 is on all fours with our own
cs8 policy
so members you have um a parish council
you have
um
pretty much 50 of the residents
properties
of barton having supported this
application you have a ward member
supporting this application you have
a policyhook
to say that you take a different view to
officers
around cs8 and you can rely on 197c the
mppf and paragraphs 202. i'll end there
and take any questions members thank you
councilman thank you very much members
do we have any questions for our wall
member
no
councillor fleming
um
as a joining ward member and like i say
i stepped out the paris council so i
could speak on this one um has anybody
sort of uh chipped in and said they'd
rather look at this derelict rundown
house and have it refurbished and make
it make it form part of the village view
no
yeah
don't think there's any other questions
for your counselor
thank you very much
okay
um let's move into points of
clarification to our offices does anyone
have any questions they want clarifying
from our offices
council jennings
under
under permitted developments how much
would they be allowed to
extend
the property um and what is their
current proposal for the volume of
extension
i couldn't be able to tell you how much
they could do under permit development
because that would need to be assessed
under a separate application okay
and in terms of volume i don't have them
figures in front of me unfortunately
sorry okay
council mills yeah
thank you mr tim um
i mean we talked about refusal from last
time but that was because of
the parking in the garage wasn't it in
in the main we focused on that last time
around
i wasn't at the last committee but there
were three refusal reasons on the report
the same refusal reason here in terms of
the extensions and then one in terms of
the garage as well and another in terms
of the parking not meeting the
specific sizes
yeah because it says on page 40 highways
matters the property has three bedrooms
the proposal will not result in any
additional bedrooms and parking revision
for the property is therefore not
affected by the development so yes yeah
okay thank you
so that's another question
so it's still on um
it was mentioned that there's been no
comment from the conservation and
heritage officer
is that correct um so we wouldn't
usually consult the conservation officer
on proposals that affect setting of
listed building or conservation area and
usually consult them on proposals that
affect an enlisted building so things
like the fabric of it
but i know that the case officer did
have a verbal conversation with a
conservation officer and the comments in
the report reflect the conversations
with the conservation officer
that's right
you do need to submit a form of plan
application to demolish the building so
that that would have to be considered by
officers okay okay thank you
okay we've got any more points of
clarification before we move into the
debate
no in that case let's open up the debate
who would like to kick us off
if you're going to be quiet i will pick
on you council mills first
you're always picking on me mr champ um
yeah um
yeah
i mean
to me it's just a vast improvement in
what what is there at the moment and i i
think the uh
the applicant's gone a long way to um
to overcome all the problems that you
have beforehand i it
it will improve this setting um
of the village uh
i i can't think anything else to say
good about it so for me mr chairman um
i will go against the officer
recommendation of grant and i go for i
refuse to go for grant thank you is that
a proposal that is a proposal mr okay
i'm going to i will come back to you in
a minute we're going to accept your
proposal but i need to have clear
reasons why you're going against the
officer's recommendation please
cancer kendall
in light of what you've just said i'm
gonna have to think about that as i'm
speaking hopefully
i do agree with what councilor mills has
said uh i think the main concerns from
last application for christmas have
largely fallen away um
so
i am
i think my oh my god let me think about
this wording of this i i don't i don't
find this causes a substantial harm to
the the setting of the listed buildings
in the in the vicinity
uh and for that reason i would second
councillor mills proposal uh that we go
against officers recommendation and
grant
on the roof i'm not sure if that's good
um i would probably suggest that you say
you don't consider it to cause any harm
um
and that it would not in europe in the
committee's opinion yeah i think as a
decision for this would not have an
impact on the conservation area sorry
and this is
are you happy with that council mills um
i'm gonna i'm still gonna continue the
debate um if anyone else wants to speak
but while we're doing that i would put
to both of you do you want to maintain
the permissive development rights or not
my gut feel would be that we take it
away because it is quite a substantial
um
expanse on that building and i in my
view anything additional to that would
have a negative impact on the
conservation area 100 you beat me to it
okay so we'll include that as well would
anyone else like to have a contribution
towards the debate at this point council
jennings yeah
i think we should be if you're looking
for the
the reasons
yeah i'm on should be is the csa
securing optimum viable use
is a there's another
reason
to to go go that route
um
i'm struggling to see
the damage it would do
um
certainly
i don't see i would say is
it isn't less than substantial harm i
see no i see no harm
um
i think that no harm is what we've got
from council kendall's comments earlier
um
i think our plans will have something to
say about optimal viable use certainly
i've got something in my mind about it
um but i'll ask cancer fleming first i
couldn't say what he wants to say
uh really sort of matched my thunder on
that because in reality and
i
i can't find where i can see harm
where you're improving the
what everybody can see
um you know i mean in reality the people
that see it most of the people that go
to the pub
um but in reality the uh
it's a picture postcard village
and to have that in the middle of it or
very close to the middle of it isn't uh
isn't the best thing so
in terms of the amount of harm that it's
done i think it's got a positive effect
on on what the village looks like not a
negative effect
okay thank you um would you like to come
in on that
yes please thank you chairman i think uh
one thing i just wanted to pick up on
which i think is kind of where
councillor fleming was coming from so
what i've taken from the debate so far
is that members generally
are suggesting that there's no harm
caused to the conservation area listed
building if that's the case then you
don't have to demonstrate an optimum
viable use that would be if it was less
than substantial so that's the first
point the second point is because this
building isn't listed itself that test
wouldn't actually be directly relevant
anyway um so i don't think you need to
worry too much about that i think if
you're minded to say that you don't
think it will cause harm then that's
sufficient you don't need to find public
benefits in line with cs8 so i just
wanted to clarify that point and if
while i'm talking i'm going to say one
more thing so in terms of permitted
development if you could identify what
parts of permitted development you think
need to be removed
then that would be appreciated
okay um we'll do that while you tell us
if you want any conditions on this
should we go to move
and grant
okay so i've got a list of suggested
conditions um so uh three year time
limit for commencement development
development should be in accordance with
the approved plans
and we'd also want a condition to secure
a schedule of materials and finishes
and then the final condition would be
the submission of a climate change
checklist because that hasn't been
submitted yet so we'd want that
submitted prior to commencement
development
and then of course there's the suggested
pd right removal condition as well
i'm going to ask cancer kendall to talk
about pds thank you chairman um
i think while we've assessed this is not
having any substantial any harm to the
setting of the conservation area all the
listed buildings
we nevertheless i think in fact this is
here the fact that we've talked about it
so much
it's a sensitive location and for that
reason i'd suggest that all permitted
development rights be removed because
any further change that i think we would
want to go through a proper process
bring it back to the council has a
proper application because i think any
change would be significant we're happy
with what we're seeing before us but any
further change would be significant so
that'll be my proposal on that a second
that
i think that's fine yep
i think if i could just i think it might
be safer just to run through the various
parts computer development although it's
perhaps dry just to make sure that we're
all in agreement that that's what you're
after so enlargement's an extension so
that's part one um
um
class b which relates to
um oh class a a which relates to
enlargement of dwelling houses in
upwards direction that presumably would
be a no
and then we've got part b which relates
to
that reflected on the windows i always
get confused
yep so that's normal windows class b so
we want that gone
and then class c is roof lights now
that's the one i'd suggest possibly
doesn't have so much of an impact but if
members are minded to think that it does
then obviously we can remove that as
well
i'm going to stick with what i said i
would want to need any change to come
back really any change okay
um so then porch is yes
any outbuildings yes
hard services
yes
chimneys flues yeah all of the above
fine microwave antennas yes
and then i think we've reached the end
okay thank you for confirming
unless anyone else would like to speak
you're happy
right so the proposal is to grant
application 2103
995 ful white gates uh welford road and
barton um could i please have a show of
hands for all those in favor
that is unanimous so committee therefore
results to grant application twenty one
zero three nine nine five ful for the
reasons given and with the conditions we
have
marvellous well done everyone thank you
very much let's move on to our next item
now we are going to have a change in our
planning officers so we will just bear
with while they do that but our next
item is windmill farm red horse fail uh
in banbury road in ox hill our
presenting officer is alanika agnew
and as soon as she's ready she will
begin
yes
good evening
so the application site of windmill farm
is located in the open countryside along
the a422 bambury road and is marked here
by a black dot on this map
the site is 1.6 miles from the village
of oxhil
the current use of the site is red horse
veil limited a family-run independent
local business selling domestic and
agricultural fuels and building farm and
equestrian supplies the site is
industrial in nature
with large metal clad storage buildings
and a large garden center paddock and
retail spaces the curse of the site can
be seen on screen
so the proposal the application seeks to
introduce a two-story four-bedroom
manager's dwelling to the west of the
site as well as a comprehensive security
strategy including cctv a fencing to
support the existing rural business of
red horse veil at windmill farm
so the design of the proposed dwelling
is to be of red brick with dark tile and
of an l-shaped layout
the total floor area of the dwelling is
243 square meters and can be seen in the
current slide
the application proposes a new route for
the public right-of-way to the western
boundary of the site
as defined by warwickshire county
council public rights away team public
footpath ss-17c intersects northwest
through the application site
the agent has confirmed that the
existing recorded alignment of the
public footpath will remain open and
available for public use at all times
three new fence gates are also proposed
along this existing public right-of-way
as well as a two metre high fence to the
northwest of the public footpath
so if i just use my cursor to point to
the gate so one will be here one will be
in the middle and one will be
just here adjacent to the boundary
so this slide shows the existing access
to the industrial site and we can also
see the residential driveway accessed
from the bambury road
the new dwelling will be accessed here
so this is the southeastern view of
where the proposed dwelling will be
cited as we can see there is an existing
dwelling on the application site
here the dwelling will be cited to the
left of the red storage container and
this photograph was taken facing north
the final slide shows the existing
industrial units and suppliers on site
as the case officer for this application
i'm not satisfied that the applicant has
demonstrated a functional and essential
need for a rural worker to live
permanently on the site as there is
already an existing dwelling in
conclusion the proposed dwelling would
be cited in an unsustainable countryside
location and is contrary to policy cs1
and as10 and i therefore cannot support
this application and recommend it as
refused
furthermore the development management
considerations for as10i states a case
based solely on the grounds of security
will not necessarily be sufficient if
the application was to be granted the
this argument of security could be
repeated on many other rural sites in
the open countryside
and the and the open countryside would
become dotted with isolated dwelling
thank you
thank you thank you very much indeed
okay we will call our first speakers for
this item who are miss wolly hoggins uh
on behalf of the applicants mr hoggins
and natasha de silva
who is our agent if you'd all three like
to make your way forward
good job we've got three desks
good evening and welcome to all of you
now you'll have three minutes i
understand mr hoggins i understand
you're here to answer technical
questions so i presume you won't be
speaking in that first three minutes
perfect
who's going to be doing the majority of
the talking
okay in that case
council war hoggins am i logical
sorry miss wally hoggins for the
purposes of tonight's meeting
um you'll have three minutes whenever
you're ready to start feel free to do so
i'll give you a 30 second warning for
your time is up
the physician photographs could just go
on a loop as i'm speaking is that is
that okay and the same comes to when i
say security photographs as well as
those can go just on a loop as i'm
speaking that'd be great and thank you
very much for for that
i just got new glasses here okay right
now
good evening committee
sorry
sorry to interrupt you and um so i
believe you need to make a declaration i
don't know if you were going to do that
before or after your speech i didn't
want to stop you before you did it
so if you want to do that now and i will
start the three minutes once you've done
that once you start your speech
i'm here today to speak to you as the
wife of marcus hoggins with a strident
voice as usual but i am also a
district councillor
so i do have an interest in this as a
wife a loving wife
as these slides are about to show you
perfect thank you very much
i've reset the clock
i've reset the clock your three minutes
will start when you start speaking
good evening committee i'm joined here
today uh by my hard-working husband
marcus hoggins who i love and respect
with every fiber of my soul
we currently live in a very comfortable
and generously proportioned house in a
lovely village which we have very
happily called home for nearly 10 years
we are here today however to ask the
permission to build another family home
adjacent to red horse fail in knoxville
for security and expansion needs
these are the views that you are looking
at that our new home will have so our
request for planning permission is
clearly done out of necessity rather
than desire
red horse fuels has been a family run
business by the hoggins family for over
60 years
security photographs please
to put the security need into sharp
focus red holds fuels a turnover in
excess of 15 million pounds it employs
45 members of staff it delivered 21
million litres of oil last year it has
the capacity
of 550 000 liters of liquid fuel storage
which includes kerosene white and red
diesel it has nine tankers valued at
nine hundred thousand ten delivery
trucks valued at three hundred thousand
plant machinery valued at 350 000 and we
store 250 gas bottles a value of a load
on a tanker is 14 000 this is not a
large garden center
we currently deliver 2 500 tons of logs
a year which we process and dry our dry
ourselves and we are growing our wood
pellet business
fuel and its price and availability is
making it a very high value commodity
and it is inevitable that it will be
targeted by both criminal gangs and
petty thieves across the country
ian king's police report in front of you
gives a very clear picture of why this
property is needed in terms of security
it is clear that we are very susceptible
to the work of criminal gangs precisely
because of the high value fuel products
that we sell and our rural rural and
very isolated location
terry hoggins the other applicant
already lives on site but is currently
carrying the unacceptable burden of
security on his own he lives alone and
as such a security need for someone to
be permanently on site he has not taken
any annual leave for over four years
times are changing we want to expand
further which refers to policy cs22 in
order for the business to grow and
function at an optimum level we must now
be able to take bulk deliveries of fuel
24 hours a day as shortages mean that we
are no longer in a position to specify
daytime delivery only 30 seconds the way
that people shop is also changing and we
want to change our current practices
we want to be able to supply and deliver
the more environment-friendly but
currently very expensive hvo fuels this
will be impossible without additional
security
the handling of fuels is a very
specialist matter and those involved in
it are required by law to hold an adr
certificate just employing a night watch
person is therefore
not an option
marcus can expand on
extending the business thank you
thank you very much that was spot on
three minutes members do we have any
questions
for our applicants please
counsel i think council mills was first
so cancer mills
thanks miss jim um sarah how many
um
how many people do you employ there
45 members of staff currently obviously
we
as the business
for business to expand we would be
looking at employing employing more
i would go i'll just make some notes
here i was going to ask you to expand on
the security but i think you've given us
all that
we've got cctv it's they've got cctv
cameras yeah throughout and um it's just
a question of being vigilant really but
it's planning for the unknown really i
think which is what we're doing all the
time now
with
we just seem to lurch from one fuel
crisis
to another in varying degrees at the
moment and the how much did the value go
up on oil last night was it 10 10 10
pence a liter oil went up last night
and that is quite a scary thing because
just
sorry is that is that relevant i just
wanted you to maximize i was letting you
speak because it made sense but i think
we probably you've answered the question
i think so thank you um thanks well
while i've got the microphone on um the
security cameras are they monitored by
the property that's on the house sorry
on the site are they monitored
externally by a third-party provider
on-site okay thank you councillor
kendall you had a question yes thank you
chairman it's just to expand a little
bit more on
you mentioned you said um employing a
night security watchman is not a viable
option why is it not a viable option
if you wouldn't mind turning your
microphone on for that thanks
uh it's just another uh
problem to deal with um personally i
think we could me and my brother can
deal with it better
um
we've tried uh those sort of things in
the past and
sometimes they turn up sometimes they
don't so it's
it's one of those situations where
it uh um
and
getting the people of not always get adr
certificates which me and my brother
obviously have
um
reliability is it sounds like it's like
what you're saying
okay and it's very much a family firm so
it's [ __ ]
sure council crump
i think to expand on that i think
um
sarah
i won't call you council or mrs because
it gets all confusing um
apologies um
i think you said in your
presentation
that there were deliveries at night as
well because of changing the way it
supplies is that right
yeah not at the moment
could you turn your microphone on your
answer sorry
but the way the world's changing i don't
think we've got much option quite
frankly
so you're
trying to preempt what's going to happen
and therefore you would need a person
who's suitably qualified rather than
a security guard who has a qualification
okay thank you
cancer janice did i see your hand go up
earlier no counselor fleming
with storing thousands of liters of
flammable fluids on site
um does the security that you're looking
for there rely on special knowledge on
say you have a leak or you have a
problem or whatever else um and
would it mean that if you
were talking about security early you
need a specialized security not some guy
you know with an escort gun that pops
around every two hours and what you
really need is somebody on site that can
look after potential leaks and hazardous
problems yes that's that was the thing
you know i'm just asking to try and
teach some more information that's all i
was asking thank you very much
okay does anyone else have any questions
they want to put at this stage
no
okay in that case thank you very much
for the three of you for your time
contribution
and while you're making your way back to
your seats um
we will open up uh points clarification
to our officers
oh sorry we won't i'll call forward
counsellor fielding i do apologize how
could i forget you
council fielding you you do know the
drill you've got five minutes when
you're seated plugged in and set and
ready to go turn the microphone on and
do starts
quick comment i did speak to ann harry
the portfolio holder about being able to
present my case in advance so that
members could have a look at it i gather
you're not allowing it to happen
although it's available
your opportunity is now so you have five
minutes um as soon as you're ready to
start you can start so what anna said
we'll we'll discuss that in private
session not in the public
fair enough
um
clock started
this is a brownfield site it was a bus
depot
up until
the date that was given by
mrs wally hoggins the area on which the
owners want to build the house can be
classified as brownfield
i received the following comments from
one of the sdc strategic planners
in the nppf 2021 definition
clearly indicates that garden land in
built up areas that is within the
physical confines of a settlement is
definitely green field
garden land associated with dwellings in
remote
remote and countryside locations isn't
specifically mentioned however the fact
that such land is not within the list
are the
examples excluded from the previous from
the definition of previously developed
land suggests the garden land in remote
locations it's
considered to be previously developed
land therefore it would be arguable the
site of the proposed dwelling could be
classified as brownfield
cs22
the requirements for business investment
in the district that are not
specifically catered for elsewhere in
this policy
will be considered thoroughly it will be
supported where the economic and social
benefits of an individual proposal
outweigh
any specific harm likely to be caused
opportunities for
business development will be provided in
the countryside including farm-based
activities in accordance with
policy as-10 the expansion of businesses
in their existing existing location will
be supported
subject to the scale and the type of
activities involved the location
and nature of this site and the impact
of the character character of the local
area this business is a very important
part of the rural community and the
proposals
though
will improve through improved security
will help the business to expand as we
discussed
nppf 85 planning policy and decisions
should recognize that sites to meet
local businesses and community needs in
rural areas may have to be found
adjacent to or beyond existing
settlements
there are other mitigating circumstances
that could be considered on page 10 of
the report
warwickshire police comments isolated
nature of the site makes it a target
for theft overall security is not
to high standards the presence of a
capable guardian is a proven deterrent
the dwelling should be of doc q
standards and the the dwelling
will provide opportunities for detection
and further crap prevention of crime
rural locations have seen an increase in
crime
the criminals are well organized and
will spend their time investigating the
target
therefore a business like red horse
fields needs to have good security
other
other aspects of running a business of
this nature are deliveries of products
there must be somebody on call at all
times to allow these deliveries to take
place red horse is the main supplier of
both diesel and central heating as
you've heard to the local community
and there are other high-end products
such as
riding equipment
the accommodation proposed is for one of
the business partners it's unfair that
the brother who lives on site has their
sole responsibility for secure security
therefore the needs for additional
accommodation
important
one of the partners must be on site at
all times
i've worked in the security industry
it's important that two people on the
premises if the alarm goes off one must
investigate
in case it's a false alarm the other
watches on cctv
the police are not happy about false
alarms
therefore cs 22
the two references to the nppf 2021
must be considered in supporting this
application plus cs1 where one should
look towards giving approval
cs2 and three to do with climate change
and emissions less vehicles on the road
because they don't have to go over 30
seconds
and cs
9 distinctiveness
it turns out i didn't need a second
warning
it turns out you didn't need a 30 second
warning members do we have any questions
for cancer fielding please
no in that case cancer filming thank you
very much your time contribution
this time we will throw it open to
points clarification officers members do
you have any points of clarification
that you would like to ask at this stage
no
let's dive into the debate then who
would like to kick us off
i'm going to start picking on people
now so curtis is looking at me very
intensely at the moment i might pick on
him first would you like to start us off
council curtis
i'll i'll kick ass i mean
it seems i can see
the
objections there is a property already
there
but
we know
what incredibly uncertain times we live
in
um
this is an isolated
environment
we know that rural crime is certainly on
the increase
and it seems to me that whatever the the
the planning merits or otherwise of this
it seems that this is not that the the
owners of the business are trying to
take the opportunity to future-proof the
business
in the best possible way and i i think
that there you know there are
opportunities to
support rural business and i think we
should perhaps consider how that could
be achieved
thank you very much for coming uh would
anyone particularly under pressure would
anyone else like to contribute at this
point cancer mills cascade scooter you
microphone off for me please thank you
councilmembers uh yeah thanks mr
chairman you'll you'll be uh
uh do you like to know i did go on site
list of this and look at it from um
a very very busy a four to two um which
they're right next to so you're right
next to the a44242
and
i would say this is
i've made some notes out of necessity
not choice because uh
well i can see where the house would be
they're facing a
green
huge building and then the rear of them
it is a
massive pile of locks that's hard part
of your thing of beauty so um
you know i i i think this stout and
second out of necessity um
and
as it was mentioned before uh
by council fleming there um if there was
a problem with um
a leak or whatever um
in the evening at night time
and somebody who is qualified to um
plug the leak i think we need someone on
uh on standby um the fact that uh
i think they said that um
the resident living in in the uh
existing houses hasn't
been been orderly for for four years
says it all i mean
one person can't look out it's a huge
site it's massive
uh and there's a lot of money involved
there so uh they are quite vulnerable
there uh it is isolated um
so there are mr chairman thank you very
much i'm not sure i can ask you for a
proposal from that i think i feel like
you were directing that way but you
never actually got that in there did i
no
well i'm going to need one at some stage
but i'm not going to put any pressure on
you right okay
because i will need reasons to go
against officers recommendations so you
can think about that before you do it
counselor jennings
so one question which i guess i should
have asked earlier could this uh
building be tied to the business
i think simple answer is yes yes we
could put condition on that
while we're on that i'm assuming
obviously there's already a dwelling on
on site or adjacent to in the
the land ownership there's no way we can
tie that
because it's already there we can't
retrospectively put on it when we
wouldn't be able to do that through 106
either
you have to think about that for five
minutes and we'll we'll continue
speaking um cancer mills yeah i'll just
say i'm just um getting my notes here
it's very similar to when we had uh
king's carton isn't it um uh
last
planning meeting but just very similar i
thought
i i wasn't here at the last one friday
and it's pronounced
thank you chair um i'd just like to
support what my two colleagues have
already said i work for a company that
sells fuel
prices are going up what the applicant
said about the prices going up and how
vulnerable they are because of their
location for theft
and so i would support them in that and
also the fact that they do need somebody
on site who has the knowledge to deal
with any
thing that might happen you have to have
special qualifications to take
deliveries just everyone can't do that
and the knowledge of how to deal with it
if there is a problem
thank you very much
um councillor crump come to my rescue
thank you mr chairman um yeah i i must
admit i'm quite supportive of this
application um for several reasons one
uh supporting a major employer in the
in aurora location as well because lots
of our
uh our employment is in the towns but
people who live in in rural locations
need some jobs as well and also if it's
in the rural location they i don't have
to travel
to the towns or the villages to get jobs
so
sustainable let's put
put some jobs where people live
um supporting local business
safeguarding employment potentially and
also expanding as well so again adding
to the economic vibrancy of the business
and also the prosperity of of the
district
um
as you know i've got a couple of roles
at county council one of which is
community safety
so i think the issues regarding security
are valid ones
especially
with the amount of thefts in in the
countryside of high value items
and you know
a can
a tank full of petrol
in a car is a high value item you'll own
uh
thousands of liters of
diesel in a massive tank
so i think there's security issues there
um
and there's also i think environmental
issues i think it's not been touched on
again from fire and rescue we've had
major incidents in
in warwickshire recently we've had
obviously the ettington
recycling center which again thanks to
great work by workshop fire and rescue
they saved from a real environmental
disaster below the run offs and things
like that and i can well imagine
that it's this place if ever took hold
this would be a serious issue an
environmental disaster
and also a transport disaster because if
we're right next to the a422 it is 422
not 442 isn't it that's football wasn't
it
so i think we've got
we've got issues regarding that as well
you know um so i think i'll again
support local business
safeguarding employment and potentially
creating employment
security issues from a community safety
point of view
transport issues potentially and
environmental issues
because again you need the specialist
person on site
to deal with any issues and as the old
saying is stitching time saves nine
because that person being on site might
be able to do something in 15 minutes
whereas if somebody had to come from
elsewhere
um we all know that like recycling
centers get
take hold quite quickly if this if that
person's and i can deal with it so
slowly i've been slightly long-winded
but hopefully i've got my point over
i think that was very helpful actually
council very comprehensive um it's
starting to sway me a little bit i'm
assuming that that is a proposal to
grant
i would either second catch the mills is
or or police i think i think i'll ask
you to formally propose because we
haven't had it proposed anywhere else so
i'm going to assume that's you proposing
um
i'm also going to assume that you want
to tie
for the building to be tied to
the business and occupied only by
um either senior manager or owner or
something so that of that yeah somebody
appropriately qualified yeah
yeah um
yeah also i would say that the reason is
that we feel
that the applicant has demonstrated a
functional
or essential need for a rural worker to
live permanently on a site in this
countryside location because of the
community safety because of the fire
environmental issues and also
supporting a local business
for prosperity of
the local area creating employment for
rural location and also the general
prosperity of the district
um
yeah so i was going to follow up on on
that as well i think i suppose
specifically it's the nature of what's
being stored on the site um both being
of high value but also uh chemical uh
explosive et cetera et cetera et cetera
uh flammable rather than explosive
probably would be a more appropriate
word um
we do have to bear in mind that there is
already a dwelling on site
you're still happy
because there's one dwelling on site
that is being used for the same purpose
you're still happy that a second could
be introduced
purely on this site because of the
nature of what's there
i'm thinking i don't want this to become
a precedent for us to see lots and lots
of it i think this is a unique set of
circumstances um
and
unique sexism and i don't believe the
the buildings on on site unless i miss
heard
has got to tie to the business it
doesn't so it could be sold as a note
mark
which is why i'm with uh have our sister
looking at an s106 potential s106 that
would make me feel a lot more
comfortable in s106 whereas without that
i'm a little uncomfortable and i need to
make it absolutely clear and i and have
it absolutely clear from all of you that
this is purely based on the
circumstances of this site
um and the nature of what's there
young so i think it's unreasonable to
expect just one person to do the
security
but this and this is i guess this is
what i'm trying to say is that that we
could have this that this we could grant
tonight and that building be uh put in
place and then the other dwelling be
sold off a separate market and then we
still only have one so we still find
ourselves in the same position i don't
think for one second that that is the
intention of the applicant but we need
to make sure that if we're granting this
for the reasons that we've set out that
those reasons we'll maintain in
perpetuity not
uh be taken away from actions that we
have no control over if that makes sense
um
i'm going to call on mater to give us
his view on the s106
i'm actually not happy because basically
um
the
dwelling at the moment hasn't got a tie
to it
um
so i mean it's it's an open market
dwelling
if you're applying a tie to the other
dwelling that's is proposed to be built
then
basically you're you're applying the tie
there but the other dwelling is as it is
at the moment
so i feel uneasy by
placing a section 106 and i'm not too
sure whether we can do it anyway but
um
it just feels that that's not what's
been requested as part of this
development
this development is for just a single
property it's not mentioning the other
property on the site so
i i mean we could adjourn i could ask
the planning managers and see what the
planners think but
i'm not too keen to add a section 106 to
this
but can we adjourn for two minutes chair
um
i'm happy to adjourn um let me just take
the view of committee members do you
how do you feel about proceeding do you
want do you feel wed to that s106
i i feel are very uneasy about it at the
moment without it but as we're hearing
it it might not be possible do you think
you can proceed do you as members think
you can proceed without it or would you
like to have a german and get some more
information
cancer journeys i think with two minutes
i'm happy two minutes we're happy to
wait okay
in that case we will adjourn for two
minutes and then we will reconvene
please don't go too far because we will
be straight back in
okay members we are we are all back now
um so i've been given uh the appropriate
legal advice so in a nutshell
um if you're minded to grant with
obviously with the tie to the dwelling
that is being proposed
just that
then we can carry on and proceed but if
you're uncomfortable as i've expressed
in my view uh about the other dwelling i
mean the potential for it to be sold in
open market um in order to put any form
of tie on that there appears to be
precedence but we need to check it and
we we would be i would certainly be
minded to uh push for a deferral if we
go down that route so
or we can refuse um so you've really
we've got sort of three options
available to us
i'm going to open it up to you all to to
give your views now council kendall's
already indicated that he would like to
speak so while he's doing that if anyone
else wants to stick that hand up i'll
make a note but cancer candle up to you
thank you chairman i was going back and
forth during the debate about about
one particular point that's been made
without about this need for security to
put somebody on site to make the site
secure and this is why i asked the
question uh earlier on which was you
know what sort of security why can a
private security firm not be brought in
to secure the site at night and protect
it from i don't know thieves and robbers
and gangs and all of this
my real problem is that i'm
i'm not convinced that just putting
another house on site
is going to provide that security that
the applicant says they need
um in fact i go further i'm worried that
what you're i understand the argument by
the way for having an expert on site
that can deal with flammable liquids and
you know stitch in time et cetera i get
that
but i'm uncomfortable with the idea of
putting what is a family home on this
site as a way of of
securing the site
which could be actually quite dangerous
i mean you know i'd turn about all of
you but i tend to go to sleep at night
and i dare say the people living in this
house will go to sleep at night so if
they're asleep at night how is that
really a measure of security unless
they're committing to you know walking
patrols of the site all night and you
know and roaches and things like that
for me that this argument that putting a
dwelling house
on this site is a measure of security
for me it doesn't hold water um and that
really gives me some problems so i'm
just not convinced on that argument so
unless somebody else has you know in
this form of debate any an argument
against what i'm saying i'd i'd be
following the officer's recommendation
uh based on that alone i think because
it's the argument's just not been made
for me
thank you kendall councillor krump yeah
i just come back
first point uh you raised i would be
happier if we went down i would like the
section 106
route potentially
um but just going back to catch the um
candles
point it's not a securities run it's a
manager's dwelling and the manager will
be taking responsibility for the site
according to
it says description of development
cctv fencing and the manager's dwelling
and i think that's a bit of a subtle
difference
so therefore
you know
the manager i see danny's got his hands
up please sir um
i think i know what's he going to say as
well but
cancer kendall it's a subtle difference
but it's not what was made it's not the
point that's been made constantly
tonight the the points been made about
security security security now that
that's the that's the argument and that
that's the argument that a lot of
you seem to be basing your decision on
about security now i understand council
crime you just switched it slightly back
to managing this dwelling but the
argument has been made all night it's
about security so again it doesn't
convince me
you last chance cancer crump because i'm
not going to have you two bicker all
night all right upset for dissension um
yeah now i would say i think it was
came out as part of the presentation
that
it's not security it's the fact that
it's
enhanced knowledge to be able to deal
with complex issues that arise and also
to future-proof the business against
changing market needs which involves
deliver potential deliveries during the
night as opposed to just set times
during the day i think we've done that a
bit to death i i i
i can see both of your arguments um yes
there is that element but the vast
majority of justification has been based
around security um i think we can just
leave that to one side for the time
being councilman mills but yes thanks
for
all i can say in my notes and i've said
it before
is it out of necessity not for choice i
mean if you if you ever go and visit the
site you think would anybody want to
build a house here it's
it's out of necessity not for choice and
i'm sure that they've
thought of this and security does come
into it and
and an engineer on site who can deal
with any problems
um
i think it's a must so um yeah arms jim
thank you okay i i think we've
canceled janice
and
my my i think my thoughts the way i'm
going on this at the moment is this
deferral on
and uh
106 agreement on both houses if that was
if that was in place i'd
i would be
[Music]
i would be happier
um
if i was to sort of
if i wanted to if this was mine i'd find
all sorts of ways if i wanted to turn
that into a housing housing
estate i could quite easily think i
could i could do that if we were to go
down this route because i'd sell i'd
sell the other market market house i'd
then turn around and say well you we
need two houses there for security so i
need to build another house let's not
give people ideas now
i think you've made your point
so are you proposing a deferment um so
that we can
further explore either a condition or a
106 to tie both properties too that's
where i'd be happy is that a proposal
could use a proposal thank you
i'm quite happy to second that
um councillor crump you proposed to
grant and you gave your reasons for that
that was tying in the property that's
been proposed now not the second one it
hasn't yet been seconded i don't think
um are you still willing for that to
proceed
um i'm happier to go down the section
106 route and it's 106 or conditions
and i think it'll give the applicant
more opportunity
to demonstrate um
the functional need for it because i
think that in the application itself
it didn't come out as much as it did
during the presentation so i think
there's an opportunity there
for various benefits the technical
reasons the fact it's not just security
in fact it's a manager's one
um
and things like that okay so so you're
happy for your proposal to fall away i'm
very happy brilliant counselor curtis
you've got a hand up
i'm sorry thank you yes it was just for
the clarification really if we go for
deferral what sort of time scale what
might we be looking at for this to come
back um i would imagine next available
um planning committee uh the agenda for
the next for two weeks has already been
set i believe
so we're probably looking first or
second one in april but it does depend
on yeah applications
soon yeah relatively soon we're not
going to unduly waste time
on the 30th of march
yeah there's one on 30th of march so
it's a possibility we're not going to
unduly waste time and delay we want to
get a decision made
okay
does anyone else want to contribute to
the debates at this point we do have a
proposal proposal to defer has been
seconded by myself could i please have a
show of hands
that is unanimous marvelous so committee
have after a lengthy debate
uh resolve to defer application 2103 992
full windmill farm red horse fell
limited
ox hill
okay
we will move to our final item of the
evening and we do have a change of
planning officer again so bear with us
while that happens but our final
application will be twenty one zero
three six four two ful wayside in
fairfield in loxley our presenting
officer will be louise casey as soon as
she's settled so louise don't rush as
soon as you're ready you can start
thank you chairman this application
seeks planning permission for the
erection of two replacement dwellings
the application site is situated to the
west of the village of loxley and is
shown here by the black dot
the application site is outlined here in
red
it's located within the felden partland
special landscape area and there is a
public footpath which coincides with the
access road to the front of the site so
public footpath runs along here
here we've got an aerial view of the
site so showing the extent of the
application site
surrounding setting is ruling character
there is only sporadic built development
within the nearby vicinity
so moving on to the existing and
proposed site layout plans
wayside is currently situated with an
area prone to surface water flooding so
this is wayside here the proposal would
result in the demolition of wayside and
the relocation of this replacement
dwelling further away from the drainage
channel the land formerly occupied by
wayside and its garden is proposed to be
changed back into agricultural use
although the dwelling is to be relocated
the overall residential cut
existing elevations of wayside and
fairfield the properties are simple in
design and single story in height the
existing overall height of the dwellings
is around five meters
and here we've got the proposed
elevations of the replacement dwellings
front and rear so the properties would
be significantly larger than the
existing bungalows and would introduce
an additional story the properties would
have five bedrooms and would stand
around eight meters in height or just
under
so crucial to this application is the
existence of a permitted development
fallback option which is a material
consideration in the decision
applications have already been approved
by the council which would allow
single-story rear extensions and first
floor extensions to each of the
bungalows
the submission has further demonstrated
that single-story side extensions could
be constructed under permitted
development the extensions that could
take place
to the dwellings are comparable in
volume to the proposed replacement
dwellings so in this slide we can see
the um the first floor that could be
added to each of the bungalows under
permitted development
so here we've got some images of the
application site in the top left corner
we can see wafe
fairfield
bottom left corner is wayside there are
existing detached garage buildings
between the two properties and then the
image on the right is just looking
forward to looking toward the two
bungalows from the access road to the
west
and
here another two images on the left hand
side we can see the field to the east
that would be developed as part of the
proposals with them shifting to the east
and on the right hand image we can see
the drainage channel that runs next to
wayside
and then these final images
are of the wider site and just
illustrate that the rural surroundings
so please see the update sheet for
updates in relation to this application
uh chairman it is recommended that the
application be granted subject to the
conditions set up within the officer
report thank you
louise thank you very much indeed okay
can we call on our first week for this
item was councillor dan bake
councillor bake good evening and welcome
i don't know why i thought you're going
to come from the other side of the room
thank you very much for your patience
um you've probably got an understanding
of the drill by now three minutes i'll
give you a 30 second warning whenever
you're ready feel free to start
good evening everybody
uh loxley parish council object to this
development as we believe it to be too
large and an over development of the
site
a violation of policy h5 of our adopted
ndp
the proposed proposed plan falls within
are on the boundary of a special
landscape area
louise might be able to clarify that
and the additional flaw being added to
the development will have an adverse
impact on the views
specifically from goldicut road
now this would be a violation of policy
ne1 subsection 2 of the ndp
development of this type has caused lots
of to have a disproportionate housing
per portfolio
in part to over development of small
properties like this one
this is backed up by the findings in our
housing needs survey and throughout the
ndp document
thank you
okay members do we have any questions
for councillor bake please
councilman
thank you thank you
hello good evening um you say the the
views will be split up from
is it the gold cop road
um
because it's quite isolating isn't it
the two bungalows
so it only be
a sport for me if you're looking
right in front of it
but either side of that it wouldn't
abuse you sorry council council back
sorry could you tell me my phone thanks
sorry yes um if you've read our ndp
that particular bit of road because it's
public access
um because of this area being classified
as
a special landscape area
the topography obviously is is that hill
area
and this is where louise would have to
just clarify i think it falls within it
yeah it does um the boundary of the
special landscape area
is
here and it's everything to the south
basically of this access road is all
feld and portland special landscape area
so the
the point was i was making at the moment
because they're single story bungalows
with uh little vegetation to hide they
they are viewed you can see them at the
moment
i think if that goes to a house dwelling
a second story they become
very visible and that needs to be taken
into consideration in an area that we
have already deemed to be
you know should be kept for a rural
landscape
okay anyone else have a question cancer
curses thank you um
thank you dan um you mentioned the the
um
local housing needs survey can you give
us a little bit more
detail of what you feel is required
okay so when i talked about um the
disproportionate
um portfolio of housing we've got
historically um and this has been
documented again in the ndp um we've
we've found smaller
properties like this um these are x um
kind of tenement buildings they're for
farm workers i would say historically
um
they have been over developed into five
six bedroom executive properties
um and that that
we've seen probably i think there's 10
or so in the last 20 years which have
gone from cottage size to five six
bedroom um and what that does is it top
ends our portfolio um which the knock on
effects we can't have downsizing for
people who already live there
um taking away bungalows i'm
i'm not going to wax lyrical about that
okay any other questions
nope in that case council speak thank
you very much your time and thanks for
your patience this evening
okay let's call on our final speakers of
the evening who are mr andrew murphy and
paul phillips are applicants good
evening both and welcome and again thank
you for your patience as well
um mr murphy i'm going to assume you're
going to do all the speaking
perfect okay in that case you're three
minutes i'll give you thirty second
morning whatever i start yes oh thank
you you've got the uh permitted
developments
oh to you thank you chairman
the existing bungalows were built in the
1960s with low quality building fabric
minimal insulation and lacking
architectural merit
the dwellings are located down a private
road 600 meters away from the public
road
the western bungalow is in a surface
water flood risk zone and flooded
recently
in july 20 2021 prior approval was
granted by this council
for an eight meter deep rear extension
and an additional floor to each bungalow
there is also scope to extend each
dwelling to the sides without needing
prior approval and you can see the plan
there showing them laid out for you
now these lawful permitted development
extensions will result in each dwelling
more than doubling in footprint and
their height rising from 4.9 metres to
8.4 metres
rather than implementing the permitted
development
this proposal seeks their demolition and
replacement with new family homes the
replacement houses have less height and
a smaller footprint compared to the
permitted development fallback houses
their volume and cartilage is about the
same
for this reason the application complies
with core strategy policies cs20 and
neighborhood plan policy h5 and is
recommended for approval by officers
prior to this submission the applicant
attended a locksley parish council
meeting
to present the project and was commended
for doing so by district councillor
o'donnell
there are no objections from
neighbouring houses
however the parish council objects on
the grounds of alleged overdevelopment
in a rural
setting despite the applicant's
consultation with the parish council it
seems they do not accept the fallback
position of permitted development
extensions which will result in large
family homes on the site
and there are many public benefits of
this proposal
so firstly
rather than an additional floor and
ungainly flat roof extensions via
permitted development
the new houses will have a coherent high
quality design more in keeping with the
rural vernacular and the district design
guide
the replacement houses will benefit from
a higher performance in terms of energy
efficiency and insulation
unlike permitted developments rights
the renewable energy is a requirement
via planning condition and will also be
incorporated
30 seconds thirdly a large structural
landscape belt on the western flood zone
will enhance visual immunity and
increase biodiversity
and fourthly both replacement houses are
located outside the flood risk zone and
this is a major environmental benefit
and is encouraged by planning policy
finally i i emphasize that the scale of
this development is the same as the
fallback position of permitted
development house extensions i ask you
to support the officer recommendation
and grant planning permission
and if you just put up the photographs
of the flooding
that's my final comment thank you
marvelous thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions either
for our applicant or the agent council
curtis
uh yes thank you just just one quick
question you um you mentioned that there
were no objections from neighbouring
houses
can you just say how far away the
nearest neighboring property is
yes there's uh one house to the west
that
two to three hundred meters away
another one to the right which is again
about two different
thank you thank you
cancer crumb
very very quickly um
two i'll probably mr murphy um
so they're going to be smaller than what
would be permit under limited
development or the same size you say
uh that same volume yeah but less height
was that right yes
and
more energy efficient
okay anyone else have any questions
before we move on
no in that case both of you thank you
very much for your time and
contributions this evening
okay points clarification to our
officers who would like to kick us off
with that
councillor crump jordan to
ask the same ones you've just asked you
want confirmation of those could uh
could i confirm that they
would be a similar size but less volume
and um
more energy efficient
than the current permitted development
proposals
so the original house can be extended
under permitted development to
1913 cubic meters
um the proposed replacement dwellings
would be 1
938 cubic meters so there's about 25
cubic meters difference replacement has
been ever so slightly larger in cubic
volume
um
and again
the total height under permitted
development
would be 8.4 meters whereas the
dwellings proposed here would be just
under eight i think about 7.95 there
would be
in terms of energy efficiency um i note
that
the applicant did submit a climate
change checklist and within that they
have highlighted that they would be
using
air source heat pumps
as long with other measures which we
could secure via a condition ensuring
that the development was carried out in
accordance with those measures set out
in the checklist
okay any other points of clarification
no in that case let's say most debate
council jennings please
right this is all about permissive
development fallback um
energy efficient the new house would be
energy efficient higher build quality
and you're moving houses to outside of a
flood area the height is less
um i see no material planning reasons to
go against the officer's recommendation
and i propose that we grant thank you
very much councillor kendall
thank you chairman um yeah i completely
agree with what council jennings has
said
although i would want to say i certainly
sympathize with the parish council i can
understand how
annoying it can be sometimes because you
just see a sort of a creep in terms of a
change of nature of a village and i
understand obviously very well i used to
go to school there when i was a kid so
yes i know loxley well and i do
certainly sympathize
but if we were to do anything other than
follow the officer's recommendation this
would likely end up an appeal and like
counts jennings says there's no real
planning grounds to go against it so
i'll happily second the
proposal council kendall thank you very
much anyone else want to say anything
counselor curtis i think it's just about
the
the right of way
but actually just echoing counseling
comments i mean
i see that really
we haven't got a lot of choice i just
wish they were more modest dwellings
that were met the local housing need
more effectively um but actually i was
just um
the um right of way
there's a public right of way
alongside are we
happy that
this isn't going to be in any way
enclosed with a sort of
six foot fence either side can we can we
attach any sort of condition to ensure
that the the right of way is kept open
as far as possible
uh county rights of way have been
consulted on the application and they've
suggested notes and conditions they've
said no objection subject to that and
it's covered in the officer report as
well fine great
because you're turning your microphone
off for me cancer curtis thank you can i
answer seraphim
um i can't see any planning reasons to
refuse this uh
it would probably look better than
permitted development so i'll agree with
what counselor kendall said marvellous
okay we've had a proposal that has been
seconded to grant in line with the
officer's recommendation unless anyone
else wants to say anything more in the
debates could i please have a show of
hands for those in favor of granting
that is unanimous so
uh committee resolve to grant
application 2103 642 ful wayside in
fairfield in loxley
um do we have any urgent business
we do not in that case members members
of the public all contributors thank you
very much your time and contributions
this evening we'll close the meeting
there thank you